la reconocida revista estadounidense
Time cumple 100 años este viernes desde
su inicio el 3 de marzo de 1923 se ha
convertido en el medio más leído en
Estados Unidos publicando más de 5.000
ediciones y sumando más de un millón de
suscriptores
todos estamos inundados de millones y
millones de imágenes que nos lanzan cada
día
siempre es gratamente sorprendente ver
como una portada de Time puede abrirse
paso en ese abarrotado panorama
mediático una portada de Time tiene que
ser Clara gráfica y a veces provocativa
pero siempre intenta arrojar un tema de
importancia dentro de ese marco rojo
intento pensar en ella como un póster
periodístico de nuestro tiempo
la figura de su primera portada fue el
legislador republicano Joseph Canon
quien anunciaba su retiro como
presidente de la cámara de
representantes a lo largo de su siglo de
existencia la revista ha sacado
ejemplares que trascendieron como la de
abril de 1966 cuando preguntaban Dios
está muerto o hay polémico titular eres
lo suficientemente madre
también se han ocupado de temas
históricos como el ataque de las Torres
Gemelas en 2001 y han graficado la
realidad con El retrato de Aisha una
mujer afgana a quienes los talibanes le
cortaron la nariz y las orejas en 2010 o
ironizando sobre la postura migratoria
estadounidense durante el gobierno de
Donald Trump con el título Bienvenidos a
Estados Unidos la guerra en Ucrania no
pasó desapercibida y le otorgaron la
distinción de personaje del año al
presidente boladímir selenski y el
espíritu ucraniano
Time planea celebrar su centenario con
eventos en todo el mundo a lo largo de
2023 junto a líderes mundiales y figuras
de distintos ámbitos